thanks to the tech preset brilliant for
sponsoring a section of this video in
the grim darkness of the far future
there is only well actually there's also
planets Games Workshop's nightmarish
vision of the future Milky Way has a
wide variety of planets ranging from the
horrors of terror to the horrors of
catagen to the horrors of audiences to
the horrors of Nocturne 40k has quite
literally millions of worlds some of
which we know very little about so in
this video we're going to take a look at
just 18 distinct planets and moons and
see if they could really exist according
to known laws of planetary science
between Hannah's lectureship in
astrophysics and my PhD in atmospheric
physics and to long term experiences in
the 40k hobby we have a fair set of
tools at our disposal however much like
the emperor in the Great Crusade we have
a pretty simple stance when it comes to
warps sorcery just say no we're going to
consider planets on their physical
merits as if there's no warp which we at
hand we're asking if we found this
planet in our own galaxy tomorrow would
it make sense in terms of the laws of
physics we should point out that we are
looking at all of these planets in m41
and in some cases m31 so before the
great snafu on Cadia we're talking 40k
before the return of rowboat girly-man
and note that we're not doing this to
poke holes in the setting we're both big
40k fans we're doing this to showcase
some cool bits of planetary physics and
use one of our favorite settings as a
jumping-off point and as an excuse to be
massive dorks and with that let's get
ready to purge the unclean
and planets
and what better place to start could
there be than holy terror
our very own earth with its rolling
fields beautiful oceans and verdant
forests after 38,000 years of horrific
industrialism and war terror bears very
little resemblance to our earth at some
point in the past all the water on Earth
was either used up or evaporated away
the law is a little vague about what
exactly happened to the water though it
seems likely that after millennia of
Industry and space travel and it was
just absorbed and used by industry with
presumably a closed system of drinking
water still operating on the planet if
you were to remove all water from
Earth's hydrosphere things would go very
badly namely we would all die quite
apart from the obvious threats of
dehydration and total collapse of the
biosphere water both in the oceans and
in the atmosphere acts as an important
moderating influence on the climate
areas near oceans experience a much
smaller variance in temperature between
day and night as well as between summer
and winter seas and oceans act to
moderate temperature changes by
efficiently storing thermal energy when
it's warm and releasing it when it's
cold water in the atmosphere is the most
significant contribution to our natural
greenhouse effects trapping energy in
the atmosphere and keeping the surface
warmer than it otherwise would be note
though that this isn't clouds they
actually net reflect energy away from
the earth but water in gas form held in
the air water vapor so if you were to
remove these two moderating influences
of water you would have a much colder
earth with much large differences
between day and night and between the
equator and the poles additionally as
the biosphere collapses you would lose
oxygen production by plants and the
planet would slowly suffocate as it died
of drought and with a lack of moisture
the planet would eventually become a
huge desert ravaged by dust storms and
blasted by the Sun all this being said
this is the capital of a seriously
technologically advanced Galactic Empire
if the loss of water took place over a
long period of time and if we're very
generous with how the humans in previous
millennia
geo engineered the plan
to account for all the horrific
environmental impacts they were causing
pumping oxygen into the atmosphere and
adding extra greenhouse gases to
moderate those temperatures then it
could exist other similarly ravaged hive
words like Nick Rimando seemed less
likely to support a world where all
water has been used up or boiled away
you need some serious geoengineering at
hand as will find with many planets in
this video there's not much information
to go on and we're dealing with some
pretty crazy technology not to mention
people for whom the concept of overkill
literally doesn't exist so terror is a
nightmare world kept alive by huge
amounts of arcane technology reshaping
the atmosphere but it seemed as possible
in this setting terror lives in
metaphorical darkness but could a planet
exist in near complete physical darkness
Nostromo the one-time home now blasted
collection of rocks of the Primark and
sadistic Batman konrad kurz had an
atmosphere so clogged with pollution
that no light reached the surface it may
have been the most depressing place in
the galaxy Nostromo is listed as
orbiting a dying star presumably a red
giant of some kind these are stars that
have grown old inflated and grown in
size resulting in them cooling and so
emitting less energy as radiation than
main-sequence stars like our Sun so with
less energy coming out from its star
Nostromo may have started off like earth
but could certainly have become dimmer
and colder another factor at play here
is the atmosphere on Moss trauma it's
described as being swathe in toxic smog
blocking out the sunlight across the
whole planet causing it to be extremely
cold
apart from at the equator now depending
on what the clouds are made of this
could have a few effects remember that
the atmosphere deals with two kinds of
radiation short wavelength thermal
radiation direct from the star and long
wavelength thermal radiation emitted by
the planet underneath our atmosphere
mostly oxygen and nitrogen is largely
transparent to sunlight but strongly
absorbs the long wavelength thermal
radiation white fluffy water clouds
reflects sunlight but be made of water
also absorbed the long wavelength
thermal radiation trapping heat in the
atmosphere other substances like sulfur
dioxide for example though
reflect sunlight but don't trap those
longer wavelengths on earth we see
sulfur dioxide injected into the
stratosphere in the aftermath of
volcanic eruptions and we've seen it
cause significant planetary cooling so
if na strawberry had for example a low
stratosphere and so could keep a large
density of pollutants in the atmosphere
at all times then it can definitely
largely block out the Sun and cause very
dark cold world NOS drama could probably
exist next up is Mauryan and I am
delighted that we get to talk about this
in our last video on the planets in the
MCU I actually talked about how you
don't see tidally locked planets in
sci-fi much and this is a great example
of one such world yes the planet with
the finest pressed Imperial Guard
uniforms in the galaxy is tidally locked
meaning that one face constantly faces
its Sun while the other constantly faces
away if Morden is close to its star that
would mean that one side of the planet
is scorching hot and uninhabitable while
the other side is freezing cold and
permanently dark and so also
uninhabitable between the two extremes
though there would be a band of tempura
habitable land due to biases in our
observations and technological ability
to detect exoplanets nearly all the
planets that have been discovered
orbiting other stars are actually
expected to be tightly locked so we know
that these worlds can exist and further
because of the size and temperature of
the most common stars in the sky in our
galaxy we actually expect the most
abundant temperate habitable exoplanets
to be tidally locked to their stars for
something to be tightly locked it needs
to be in orbit around a larger body
within the tidal locking radius the moon
for example is tidally locked to the
earth only showing us one face at all
times this is because its orbital period
matches its rotation period so the time
taken to orbit the earth is the same
time that it takes to rotate on its axis
once but the moon isn't even the only
example of this behavior in our solar
system most of Jupiter and Saturn's
moons are also
locked to their planets due to the
moon's gradually losing rotational
energy over time so what would the
atmosphere look like on a tidally locked
world well as we've already mentioned
there could be potentially a temperate
habitable band between the light and
dark sites and you might expect there to
be very windy that'd be a constant wind
line from the warm side to the cold side
but depending on how fast the planet
orbits its star and how closely you can
get some really interesting dynamics not
too dissimilar to Earth's it still had
to be a pretty special breed to live on
such a planet though if Falls of the
morning regiment as your punishment
detail for your transgressions against
the Emperor you will march in close
order parade standard until the NCOs
have decided you've learnt your lessons
parade add vats keep going for a while
Saturn so let's talk to you in the mess
ah that'll be the shirt starch delivery
mini dog Dhruva however one thing that
stands out on the wiki page for more
daeun is that it says the planet has no
Coriolis force because it doesn't rotate
and this causes a lack of any strong
winds well that's just plain wrong for a
planet to be tightly locked it needs to
rotate and tidally locked planets have
really interesting atmospheric dynamics
this planet is so cool that we're
inclined to give Games Workshop two
writers a pass on this one
partly because that's a simple detail to
change but also because of another thing
on the wiki page where they were
actually spot-on research suggests that
tidally locked planets around bright
stars could have strong convection and
cloud formation which would lessen the
difference between the day and the night
sides but also result in a darker world
and that exactly matches the description
of more daeun right down to the
settlements being on the night side as
you'd expect when orbiting a bright Sun
so the planet absolutely could not exist
as described there add in a rotation
period that matches its orbital period
we'll give you a gold star and a
realistic depiction of a tidally locked
world another great recruiting world for
the Astro militar dawn for the Imperial
Guard is valor
Halla here the locals definitely wear
multiple thick coats due to the
extremely low temperatures it's so cold
that the planet's oceans froze solid
Baja is a frozen world knocked away from
its star by the impact of a colossal
comet having been knocked further away
from its star it makes sense that the
planet were cooled off as distance from
its star correlates well with the
planets temperature it also makes sense
that in the aftermath of the comet
impact and nuclear winter would be
triggered lots of dust and particulate
injected into the atmosphere that would
block out the Sun similar to the event
that killed off the dinosaurs combined
with the change in orbit it could be
enough to take the climate past a
tipping point
freezing the oceans permanently on human
timescales at least eventually the
planet would likely for and revert back
to a state with liquid water but over
tens of millions of years what's unusual
about this event though is the power of
the impacts and also the culprits a
comet comments are typically ice based
which could mean water ice or something
like carbon dioxide ice this contrasts
with asteroids which are basically lumps
of rock and metal the Lord describes
Valhalla as being hit by an iron-rich
comet when she doesn't really make any
sense if you have been struck by an
asteroid on the other hand perhaps flung
out on a comet like orbit in the past
then the density of iron in it would
make a lot more sense but could an
asteroid actually transfer enough
momentum to knock a planet into a new
orbit specifically we want to look at
knocking a planet just out of the so
called Goldilocks zone where liquid
water is possible on the surface of a
planet orbiting a given star a
reasonable estimate of the outer limit
of the Goldilocks zone in our solar
system is twice Earth's current orbit
now in order to knock earth specifically
to that new orbit you would need to
transfer some 1.3 million billion
billion billion joules of energy I did a
rough calculation and if we assume an
impacting asteroid was a ball of pure
iron colliding with the earth a typical
impact velocity of 13 kilometres per
second it would need to be around 12,000
kilometers across to try
for this much energy that's more than
ten times the size of the largest
asteroid we've yet observed Ceres it
would actually be about the same size as
the earth but pure iron see yeah that's
not gonna happen
perhaps Valhalla is a smaller planet
orbiting a less massive Sun but for the
reasons that will come active later in
the video
even then an impact of sufficient
ferocity wouldn't have the effect of
knocking Valhalla into a new orbit
planets can be flung to new orbits or
out of their star systems entirely by
gravitational interactions and we know
that there could be as many as 50
billion free-floating planets in our
galaxy alone but Valhalla's specific
backstory just doesn't add up 40k is so
subtle in its naming schemes after
Valhalla Hannah where are we going next
[Applause]
previously known as una noir prime
Armageddon is a blasted world with a
refreshing variety of climates jungle in
the equatorial regions fiery wastes to
the north and frozen lands to the south
which is great but this map makes zero
feathering sense this map actually looks
more like a tidally locked world with
one hot hemisphere and one cold one but
the presence of the equatorial jungle in
a narrow longitude band rather than a
latitude band in the center of the map
is just plain baffling jungles need hot
temperatures and lots of moisture as you
find in the tropics and if the jungle is
anything like what we have on earth it
should extend from west to east not
north to south as we see on the map if
we're being generous here there could be
some bizarre orographic factors at play
but this geography seems to make very
little sense another interesting part of
Armageddon's climate is the so-called
season of fire when the landscape is
beset by dust storms thunderstorms the
world is rocked by multiple volcanic
eruptions very dramatic we actually see
seasons of dust storms on earth in
places like North Africa and Australia
but also on Mars where the summer can
encase the entire planet with dust
storms with hurricane wind speeds the
volcanic aspect is more unusual but not
without precedent
volcanic activity can be caused by tidal
forces within planets and moons IO for
example has extensive volcanism caused
by its orbit around Jupiter just as the
moon is acted on by the gravity of the
planet it also is affected by the
gravity of the other moons around
Jupiter and affects which changes over
time and depending on where those moons
are in their orbit they will pull and
squeeze and stretch IO these change in
gravitational forces will lead to tidal
heating and volcanic activity if
Armageddon had an orbit around its star
that took it close to some other planets
in the system perhaps something similar
could occur here and it could also be
seasonal Hannah and I are both alt
players so perhaps we have a natural
soft spot for Armageddon but while the
season afire could possibly be explained
the climate and geography just don't
match with what we know about the planet
so get the ad mech on the Vox cast to
teleport this planet again this time to
the segment 'm nan possibilies you know
perhaps the planets in 40k aren't as
crazy as we thought they were so far
everything's been pretty normal looking
well there it is we had to look at one
completely crazy world audiences is a
slum nashi world in the eye of Tara
that's actually a colossal morbidly
obese man I think we're gonna need a
medical doctor on this one
fortunately Hannah I know just the guy
hi Simon mm-hmm you want me to explain
whether a fat man could be a fat planet
listen I've kind of got more important
things to know of course of course I
think your work is important too yes of
course I think you're a real doctor
okay just fine fine fine I'll do it okay
doctor Clark wants to know if it's
possible to have a planet sized organism
not some alien biology some amorphous
blob we're told this is a man so we
assume has mammalian biology therefore a
good place to start is comparing the
smallest mammal the Etruscan shrew with
the largest land mammal the elephant
they both maintain around the same body
temperature but how when the true will
lose body heat far more rapidly than the
elephant the cells of a shrew and an
elephant under a microscope would look
about the same they'll be about the same
size the elephant just has way more of
them so if you consider a cell at the
center of a shrew versus the cell at the
center of an elephant which has maybe 50
or 60 centimeters to get to the surface
where it can lose heat to the atmosphere
the elephant is going to lose heat far
more slowly therefore if an elephant
cell produced heat at the same rate as a
shrew cell the elephant would
immediately burn up and die or if a
shrew produced heat at the same rate as
an elephant then it would freeze to
death
this is metabolic rate so to maintain
a normal core temperature for a mammal
of around 37 degrees in audience s the
surface would have to be icy cold or if
the surface was to be maintained that a
normal body temperature then the core of
the planet would be thousands of degrees
he just think about the core of the
earth compared to the surface this is to
say nothing of the sheer impossibility
of bodily functions I mean what does he
eat how does he breathe moving the
muscles of respiration would be like
catastrophic earthquakes what gases does
he breathe his own atmosphere every
breath out would fill the atmosphere
with carbon dioxide which would
contribute to corporal warming something
that's never actually been proven on
earth and his bones would crumble under
the force of his own gravity any episode
of flatulence would be cataclysmic
chemical warfare on a continental scale
no this idea is completely unrealistic
and impossible a bit like anthropogenic
climate change two worlds where
exceptionally high temperatures are
normal though our PACCAR and nocturne
makar is described as having oceans of
lava with islands of basalt and granite
floating in them with a noxious
atmosphere of sulfur oxides and ammonia
it's where they send heretics and
penitence in the Imperium to mine
minerals and then die it is basically
spicy space Siberia well this one is
just awesome
the rafts of basalt and granite might
not make much sense at first after all
for something to float it needs to have
a lower density than a fluid that it
sits on and basalt and granite are
pretty dense after all they are rocks
however if a rock cools from lava with
enough gas in it it can have a
surprisingly low density pumice for
example is a volcanic rock so Airy that
it can float on water so combined with
convection in the lava underneath the
rafts it could conceivably be possible
to have rock rafts on top of what is
basically planet-wide lava lakes to have
such a lava lake you would definitely
need to have a very hot planetary core
or perhaps a really geologically young
planet that's still forming its crust or
possibly the planet is resurfacing
itself it's hypothesized that Venus
melts and replaces its entire surface
every billion or so years such an
activity would definitely take longer
than the ten thousand years that humans
have been active in the galaxy so
perhaps the heretics on the car
are just there at the wrong time to bear
witness to the planet melting its entire
surface almost enough to make you feel
sorry for doing so the car seems
possible Nocturne home to the galaxy's
greatest hugger on the other hand has
the huge moon Prometheus circling in an
irregular orbit much like we
hypothesized with Armageddon and the
effects of tidal heating prometheus
could produce significant effects on
Nocturne and its tectonics leading to an
extensive period of volcanic activity
the planet is described as having a time
of trial every year when volcanoes
explode all over the planet
breathing in dust and sending the planet
into a deep chill this closely matches
what we see on earth as we mentioned
earlier when discussing Nostromo big
volcanic eruptions can significantly
call the entire planet and with a huge
amount of seasonal tidal heating
supplied by Prometheus's gravitational
pull material from eruptions on Nostromo
would increase the planetary albedo
reflect more light to space and cool the
surface of the entire planet the
planetary system here though it does
raise an interesting point about moons
the Earth's is huge our moon is roughly
a quarter the diameter of the earth
which is absolutely massive compared to
other planets Neptune for example has
the next largest moon to satellite size
ratio at just 0.055 the moon being so
big relatively earth means that it has a
serious effect via tides and may have
actually been crucial to the development
of life here on earth looking at this
picture of Nostromo and prometheus the
moon is just shy of half the diameter of
the planet so an even bigger ratio than
the earth and the moon the two would
have to orbit quite far apart to avoid
tearing each other apart through these
tidal forces Pluto and its moon Charon
actually have roughly the same size
ratio and all the each other quite
closely but they seem to be much much
smaller than
system of NOS drama and prometheus so in
terms of a volcanism like the car
nostril mode makes sense something that
doesn't know unfortunately is its
atmosphere there's just no way that a
planet so volcanically active would have
a breathable atmosphere oxygen is just
too chemically reactive to be out gassed
by lava in pure breathable form it would
always come out of something like carbon
dioxide orb self a dark side
much like the idæan earth or bio in
reality Nostromo would expect yet you
before you even had a chance to burn to
death but contrast these fiery worlds
with the ice of Fenris the greatest
Viking theme park in the galaxy hello
and welcome to Fenris we have snowstorm
ah easter teal
Valhalla made of an underflow Kavya oh
and don't forget our dust museum home to
the space wolves chapter Fenris is a
totally frozen world much like puff in
star wars for discussion about the
historical precedent on earth for a
Fenris existing see our previous video
about the planets in star wars furnace
is a little unusual in that much of the
planet is still covered in liquid water
which would result in the atmosphere
holding a lot of water vapor and as
water is an incredibly potent greenhouse
gas you'd expect this to keep the planet
toasty but Fenner's could just be
further from its star than earth
combating this firmly insulating effect
and if the planet had a slightly richer
geological composition the oceans might
have a high salinity they would contain
more salt preventing them from freezing
at low temperatures
it all seems entirely possible but
femoris does raise an interesting point
that sci-fi worlds often adopt the
presence of a single biome over the
planet a biome is a community of plants
and animals that are all adapted for a
particular environment on earth there
are dozens of biomes ranging from
rainforests to tundra to Savannah all
with associated highly specialized
ecosystems
when scifi writers create one biome
planets they're effectively saying that
the climatological conditions are almost
exactly the same everywhere on that
planet sometimes this is justified as in
the case with Fenris or entirely desert
planets like
coup or Tatooine we have historical or
current precedent for these types of
worlds but what about entirely temperate
planets like for example Tanith before
its untimely destruction by the forces
of chaos
Tanith was a verdant world covered in
our word forests forests that moved the
constantly shifting landscape meant that
the world produced the Tanith first and
only regiments legendary for their
scouting and reconnaissance abilities in
order for a planet to have a consistent
temperature all over it it must have a
thick atmosphere which transports excess
heat away from the tropics and towards
the poles where it is then radiated into
space this is what happens on earth if
this heat transport is sufficient with a
particularly thick radiative lee active
atmosphere then conceivably a temperate
climate suitable for forests is
achievable for most of a planet though
on a world with water as we would assume
is present on Tanith this would have
additional complications that we'll come
back to later we know very little about
Tanith seeing as it was destroyed before
we meet gone and his friends and their
plot armor but we know that it also had
polar caps as well as huge forests on
earth we do see vast forest just shy of
the Arctic but these are very different
to the forests closer to the equator for
example so we'd have to conclude that
Tanith had a particularly thick
radiatively active atmosphere that
trapped and redistributed heat very
effectively much more so than on earth
though this would then raise the
question as to why they were polar caps
on Tanith at all perhaps the planet had
a very small axial tilts meaning the
poles were always dim and therefore cold
also we don't know the specifics of now
wood which is meant to be an animal
plant photosynthetic hybrid so we can't
say for sure what conditions it would
thrive in or if there are different
variants that specialized in different
temperatures then why do you wonder what
evolutionary advantage now would would
have in moving if the climate on the
planet is basically the same everywhere
look Hannah the planet produced eoghan
McCole the man was a downed hero in
general it would be very difficult to
produce a planet with a temperate biome
all over except for ice caps without a
pretty extreme atmospheric circulation
but dad Abner in all his infinite wisdom
didn't give us much detail to work with
so I'm happy to hand wave on this one
especially if now word came in tropical
and sub can it might be able to exist
though it still seems unlikely it's
something of a moot point now anyway but
we're on the subject of destroying
worlds
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
being god-emperor fearing citizens of
the Imperium we would never encourage
you to advance yourself through
knowledge or education but fortunately
we don't live in the 41st millennium and
science and technology both hold power
and progress and understanding promise
in ruling on the feasibility of planets
in this video Hannah and I used a
variety of techniques from physics and
mathematics for example in calculating
the energy required to knock earth to a
new orbit I use the concept of
gravitational energy an equivalent
problem is calculating the energy
required to move a ball of a given mass
in the Earth's gravitational field from
position a to position B which is given
by this expression this page is part of
the course on gravitational physics on
brilliant the educational website and
app that kindly sponsored this video
they have a huge variety of interactive
expertly written courses on subjects in
maths science and computer science if
you enjoyed the discussions in this
video then you should definitely check
out their courses on classical mechanics
and physics at the everyday well if
you'd like to learn how I created
animations like this one then check out
that course on Python there has never
been a better time to improve yourself
through leveling up your problem-solving
skills and learning more about how the
universe works I've been doing it myself
with their chemistry course and look
forward to diving into more of their
computer science courses if you'd like
to give an access to brilliant to the
student in your life or dive in yourself
then go to Belinda org slash silent
Clark and first 200 subscribers to do so
we'll get 20% off their annual
subscription thanks to the tech preset
brilliant for the support and for
generally being awesome thank you for
watching the video I really hope you
enjoyed it and learn something about
both of the physics of planetary science
or the law of Warhammer 40,000 thanks of
course must go to make us hannah for
helping make this video check out the
description for a link to her website
and research and also down there are
links to Colonel Digby Medicare Owen
Francis and gray hunter Rhydian mentions
in dispatches also too server tools dr.
David Arnold and Tom Dowling for their
errata on the script if you've not
already seen them definitely check out
our previous videos on the planets of
Star Wars and the MCU and the second
part of this video will be out in a week
or two as soon as I've recovered from
making this part do give it a share and
alike if you've enjoyed it and subscribe
if you want to see more videos like this
one thank you again for watching and
we'll see you
in party